victor le fou de sciences et dans le val
de loire sur les traces d'un personnage
hors du commun
aujourd'hui on se retrouve à amboise au
clos lucé sur les panneaux léonard de
vinci
ce génie qui a pu influencer les
inventeurs d'aujourd'hui et notamment on
a rendez vous avec jean pierre jane
brain de comprendre et nous expliquer
tout ce qu'il a pu faire en son temps
jean pierre ans qu'ils y est professeur
de mathématiques mais surtout il est
passionné par les travaux de léonard de
vinci
bienvenue déjà au clos lucé ça s'appelle
le clos lucé
c'est là où est mort léonard de vinci il
a vécu les trois dernières années de sa
vie en gros et il est décédée ici c'est
un an qu'à l'époque tout ça alors c'est
15 116,15 119
j'avoue qu'on attention et directement
capté par quelque chose que je vois au
loin on ne sait pas une hélice une pâle
alors c'est la vis est-ce qu'on peut
aller la voir on va aller la voir oui
dans les jardins les conservateurs du
clos lucé ont imaginé un parcours au fil
des oeuvres de léonard de vinci
alors les listes c'est le symbole du vol
d'un gardien ça veut dire que au départ
léonard y pense qu'on va s'appuyer sur
l'air pour voler et après non il met en
rotation cette grande vis et il pense
qu'on va s'élever à 800 dans des salles
et audard à 9 ans il a imaginé la
consule n'a pas mis en situation il ne
l'a pas cru en reprogrammant
physiquement non alors léonard-de-vinci
tout de suite mais je te dit entre nous
il a jamais construit tout ce qui la
destinée c'est dommage mais léonard
c'est quelqu'un qui ne fabrique pas ce
qu'ils décident dans quel but est ce que
léonard de vinci avait pu réaliser tout
ça lui son but c'était de faire voler
l'homme d'un qu'il adorait les oiseaux
et les a beaucoup étudié pendant 12 ans
de sa vie intérieure finale à faire
tourner un peu la vis avant qu'on parte
c'est vrai la faire tourner et retourner
aller à ça me fait plaisir mais
finalement c'est pas si simple
sait on dit que c'est pour les enfants
mais c'est quand même un petit pour
cette machine là sur le 500e
anniversaire la vis en elle-même c'est
lé symbole du 500e anniversaire en
centre val de loire
ah oui je sais quand même quelque chose
d'emblématique oui ouais pourquoi les
serbes les matines du coup bas parce que
il vole maintenant l'homme à l'époque de
léonard on n'imaginait qu'on pouvait
voler et là maintenant ça y est on vole
alors pas tout à fait comme il l'a
imaginé
on vole quand même notre coeur le maître
toscan était un intarissable et génial
touche-à-tout
voilà je te propose on va les voir un
char d'assaut
parce que léonard de vinci c'est aussi
un ingénieur militaire il ya quelque
temps à la renaissance ya pas très
longtemps qu'on a inventé les canons
elle lui propose de se protéger de
protéger des hommes et d'envoyer des
boulets à 360 degrés je te propose
d'aller voir un pont menant à pau un peu
particulier ouais on ne soulève une fois
qu'on a soulevé avec ce cabestan là on
le fait tourner donc on peut faire
passer un bateau ce qu'on veut là pour
mobiles c'est génial ça pour l'époque
finalement c'est un discours
révolutionnaire
c'est vrai qu'ils utilisent impôts comme
ça à des fins peut-être militaire aussi
un se dire voilà on doit faire passer
des bateaux une armée je sais pas quoi
c'est quand même très intéressant un
classifiable léonard de vinci était à la
fois peintre inventeur ingénieurs
scientifique humaniste et philosophe
mêmes architectes voilà tu vois victoire
là le pool fameux pour léonard on peut
marcher à deux endroits différents
imprimés dessus a priori c'est remettez
le peuple les bestiaux dessous elle est
noble dessus ou en tout cas c'est un
très beau vin